[Musique]
beat jans trading
on a une ressortissante quelques arrêtés
ça pue c'est quoi une affaire de drogue
son mari a été assassiné en fait
remarquer
[Musique]
tu étais souvenir de quoi du noir
en fait vous vouliez pas ce mariage
c'est ça comme ça mais leur tâche est
lourde et pourrit la vie avec vos
croyances d'homère
il faut pas la laisser comme ça et
personne dans sa famille n'est capable
de la protéger
mais mythe et achètent ou like 0 dit si
tu veux la vérité c'est ce qu'il faut
faire
vous croyez comprendre et vous ne
comprenez rien
mamani volta
j'apporte baixa prg
votre nouvelle série créations
originales possession seulement sur
canal+